you mentioned a few other games like the
bobby fischer games the candidates match
the game of the century
which i feel like is a is a weird game
to call the game of the century when
there's still like a few decades left in
the century but yeah i mean it wasn't an
official thing it was just the chess
journalist on a chess article but it's
stuck if you look yeah no it didn't
wikipedia this is all i do research-wise
um because there's so that particular
one was a 13 year old fisher
and he did a queen sacrifice
i wonder is it there's that movie
searching for bobby fisher was that
related because didn't they have a young
somebody who's supposed to be kind of
like bobby fischer played by josh
wadeskin yeah i think he ended up being
an international master it wasn't based
on bobby fischer's based on another
player but i liked how they told it
through the lens of being inspired by
bobby fischer do you remember that game
like why do you think it was dubbed the
game of the century it was just
journalists being like i i think part of
it was the atmosphere where you have the
us junior champion who's this 13 year
old nobody and it's the first time he's
playing in a very competitive landscape
against some of the top american players
and he goes up against an international
master so somebody who's a lot stronger
than he is who's played in you know
olympiads for the american team he's
having a bad tournament but then he has
this one game where he just
shows off his uh tactical prowess and
plays incredibly well and i don't know
if this is true but in the paper
clippings of it they'd say things like
grand masters were by the board and they
would say things like oh bobby is lost
in this position what is he doing but
there's this 13 year old kid who's just
playing incredibly well and then that
also happened before
bobby's started really rapidly improving
at chess not that people knew that but
he kind of seemed like a rising star so
i think the game was beautiful but i
also think the idea of a 13 year old kid
coming out from nowhere and beating a
top american player was very fascinating
and there was aggressive chess and it
was in the interesting ideas
yeah taking big risks it's cool to see a
13 year old do that yeah
uh what about the you you mentioned that
his match against uh
mark
taimana from their 71 candidates match
was interesting in some way why is it
interesting to you
i'm move 45 i'm looking at some notes
this is with the bishop e3 i think i
know which one you're talking about um
it's
i wouldn't say
a lot of these games on these lists i
think are really great combinations that
that
when tactics come into play which is
what we're talking about but they're
very good at exemplifying lessons
this is why you study famous games so
you can apply these lessons to your own
games and i think the main takeaway for
this one was they were punishing their
opponent from steering away from opening
principles which is something that we
learned a little earlier
where he delayed the development of his
king and put his queen out a little bit
too exposed so bobby fischer immediately
punished that and then there was just
like a beautiful combination where it
was like a
12 in a row perfect moves which was a
tactic just winning the game but it only
came from punishing those mistakes the
mistake being bringing the queen out uh
bringing the queen out and yeah not
castling your king right away
and these were just like opening
principles that now they're written in
books but but for books you would study
these principles by studying games
and also
i'm looking at some notes his dominance
during the candidates tournament was
unprecedented
he swept two top grand masters i mean
that guy's meteor cries is incredible
sad that i think at whatever in his 20s
he then quit chess
and one has to wonder what
where he could have gone
yeah it is sad that
we lost such a brilliant mind so early
on and it's also sad i think kind of
what ended up happening in his life and
the slowly going crazier
you